طيب عارفين ايام المدرسه زمان في
الامتحانات لما كنا نحل مثلا مسائل مسائل
الرياضيات مثلا او كيمياء وتيجي الاجابه
النهائيه خطا بس انه مثلا يعني المدرس او
المدرسه يعطونا كم علامه كذا تقديرا للجهد
يعني بس في الحل كده يعني علامه كده بس
عشان الشرف المحاوله يعني في اليوم خبر من
بوليفيا ذكرني بعلامات الترضيه هذه او
خليني اسميها علامات جهد يحترم بس على
الفاضي ففي مجرم في بوليفيا محكوم 15سنه
بجريمه قتل حاول يهرب من السجن وصراحه
محاوله مبتكره جدا يعني لو ينفع نحييه
عليها كان حيينا لكن طبعا قوه خرق للقانون
وهذا كمان يعني جهده كمان كله طلع على
الفاضي وبدون فايده وانمسك ترى في النهايه
فالسجين هذا اتنكر على شكل خروف ولبس صوف
على ظهره وغفل الحراسه للسجن وطلع من
زنزانته وبس وصل برا عند حقول السجن نزل
على اربعه بتنكر وهذا وصار يزحف الى ان
وصل لحدود السجن الخارجيه وحاول يتخطاها
ويهرب كل هذا زحف وعلى اربعه واستغل المطر
والظلام المهم حراسه السجن انتبهت
وانتبهوا
عليه
غير رجعوه المكان وفرضوا كمان عليه عقوبات
قانونيه وتاديبيه على المحاوله هذه يعني
[موسيقى]